hey youtubers its charlie brand new
flash the coolest thing just happened we
just learned the true origin of the
reverse flash they could do on the TV
show and the real reason why his costume
is yellow which is even more interesting
in my mind there's a new round of the
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so there have been
a couple really big reverse flash origin
stories that have been told over the
Aerith asking why did you kill my mother
because I hate you not you now new years
from now in the future in a future yes
or enemies rivals opposites reverses of
one another what why why were we enemies
doesn't matter why do you hate me so
much I didn't always
I was obsessed with him for so long I
wanted to be the flash the TV shows
largely been faithful to that through
omission like it just cuts out the
entire story just says reverse-flash
hates flash wants to get rid of them so
that's why he came back in time to kill
his mother and that's the end of it but
that's actually just because they're
saving the story for a future episode
it's too big of a story not to do and we
just learned the truth of the why like
we've learned a couple different ways
that he's become the reverse-flash so
I'll explain the changes to his origin
story in the comics but the really cool
thing is that in the grand style of Jeff
John's idea of rebirth they've updated
his origin story while at the same time
incorporating all the previous versions
of his origin story going back to the
Silver Age before this past week there
were about four different versions of
his origin story now there are five but
they all make sense together so that's
why DC rebirth is such an awesome thing
and why it makes you so excited to see
this during a future season at the flash
so starting at the beginning originally
what we learned is the eobard thawne was
from the 25th century he was walking
along with a mysterious time capsule
with an atomic clock in Barry Allen's
old costume show up just out of nowhere
the whole reason behind it is actually a
little ridiculous this is why you're
kind of glad that they update the story
just a little bit over time so a
scientist comes up with the bright idea
that they'll shoot a time capsule into
the future so that people will learn
what the past was like that's the only
reason behind it eobard thawne just
happens to be walking by when the time
capsule lands he steals the Flash's
costume from it before the authorities
can grab him and then wants to go on a
crime spree he immediately wants to be
the reverse of the flash haha I'll be
the greatest criminal in the world
Mark Waid was the first person to turn
the reverse-flash into a flash fanboy
but he finds the cosmic treadmill in an
antique shop in the future steals it
uses it to come back in time to meet his
hero but he undershoots the market
doesn't go back far enough so the flash
is dead and he's walking through the
flash museum and learns that he's
destined to become Ivar thought it
drives him mad so he gets the bright
idea I
can't become the reverse-flash if I
become Barry Allen so you have this
return of Barry Allen arc where he
pretends to be Barry even gets cosmetic
surgery to make himself look like Barry
that's how crazy he is but then during
the Geoff Johns era the big things that
he changed is that he turned professor
zoom into a professor of Flash studies
like he became an expert in flash
history he still got the costume the
same way from the time capsule then due
to his severe inferiority complex goes
on a tear killing all kinds of people
editing his own timeline like he goes
back in time and kills people to prevent
him from achieving his goals so
eventually he meets up with the flash
they fight and that's when he starts
going back in time trying to ruin the
Flash's life by killing his mother so
that he experiences all this tragedy
hopefully trying to derail his career as
the flash you get to the new 52 version
of his origin story the difference here
is that as a child he witnesses his
father kill his mother which is kind of
like the zoom origin story they did on
the TV show the TV show borrows a lot
from the new 52 do you or do you know
what I went through over there do you
know the sacrifices I made for you
so once zoom learns that the flash is so
beloved he becomes obsessed with
becoming the flash he feels like he's
destined to become the flash of the
future in demands that everyone worship
Him the same way they worshiped the
flash but they hate him so he goes back
in time recruits a bunch of acolytes
which sounds very familiar after the
flash season 3 zoom went back in time
and recruited a bunch of acolytes to
worship Him as a god none of you are on
your knees this is my most about before
deity they're not God to you gods you
just have to make people believe you are
so in this version reverse-flash winds
up killing Flash's mother so that they
both get an equal start because in this
timeline you Barth on had to witness his
mother being murdered just like Barry
had to witness his mother being murdered
the new version of his origin story
which sort of incorporates all these
different versions as well as the TV
show spelling it out is very incredible
if you remember the syndrome character
he admired mr. incredible I'm your
number one fan but mr. incredible took
him for granted
so the spurned buddy became the
supervillain syndrome I just wanted to
torment him just because he had this
crazy inferiority complex
the ultimate beta male so that's kind of
who the reverse flashes so they say is
that in his early years as the flash
sort of like where we are in the TV show
right now we're still only on our fourth
year of Barry being the flash he uses
the cosmic treadmill to go to future
central city in fines when he shows up
that the reverse flash is just sitting
there waiting for him wearing the old
costume that was sent to the future
Barry meets them he totally does not
look like a crazy fanboy look at this
look in his eyes this is so perfect here
so they start teaching each other tricks
like show me some things that you've
learned flash of the future and he calls
in the future flash which is a nice week
at all the stuff that we've been having
last season Barry throws crazy pants
eobard thawne in prison once he learns
that he had the bright idea to become
the flash by creating the need for the
blast
once again rock-solid eel bars on logic
they'll need a flash if I blow up a
building and the flash needs to save
them intakes iris west to the flash
Museum in the future Intel's bury his
origin story again and this is how you
learned the big changes from when he was
a little kid he says both of his parents
were murdered so he grew up without any
parents but he did have all of the tapes
of the Flash's saves so he idolized him
he didn't have a parental figure of his
own so he sort of put all that on Barry
Allen eventually he found the capsule
tried to become the flash of the future
and then that's when he met the flash
and the flash learned the dark truth of
how he was causing all these crimes so
that he would need to save them but as
part of his rehabilitation
he gets the police to let him become the
curator of the flash museum so
eventually once he feels like he's ready
to meet Barry Allen again he makes
himself a yellow version of the costume
because all of the Flash's sidekicks
wear yellow that's the beautiful new
reason for the reverse flashes costume
being yellow because all of the Wally
West's that had been his sidekicks in
the past wore yellow so reverse flashes
like I want to be the Flash's next
sidekick so all wear yellow like them so
he goes back in time to show Barry on
how he's become better I've fixed myself
I've been rehabilitated I'm ready to be
your sidekick now in witnesses very
sharing a moment with Wally giving him
his father's watch with a special phrase
they also shared with the reverse-flash
so he says wait a minute we weren't
special our relationship was not special
you didn't care about me at all the
Flash's a liar so I'm going to dedicate
my life to bringing you the pain that
you've brought me so it's a much more
tragic take on his backstory and it does
sound just like Incredibles I'm sorry
buddy I'm sorry I didn't pay more
attention to you I'm sorry I didn't care
about you more so whereas the previous
seasons of the flash have just said that
reverse-flash hates Barry they're saving
this type of story for a future season
so let me know in the comments what is
your favorite version of the reverse
slashes origin and while they tend to
use the character in a simpler way they
tend to use them for more straight-up
stories I feel like this is the perfect
most relatable version
they could totally do on screen this is
tailor-made for a TV episode so leave
all your flash bonus video requests in
the comments below there'll be new DC
happening later this week but there's a
whole bunch of new spider-man Marvel
phase 4 so I'll be posting that video
next congratulations to the latest flash
ring giveaway winner creator falcon
please private message me so I can get
your contact details you can click here
for my non-spoilery spider-man
homecoming review and you can click here
for a preview of what's going to be
happening during the four nye crossover
this year thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you